if someone has never seen any of your
online videos or listened to any of your
music yes what is the first thing you'd
like them starting with and why very
good question Steve look at you stunning
you really thought about this one let me
think about this one then hold on even
exchange something I want them to see
honestly I feel like I'm stepping into a
new chapter come on I feel like I'm in a
more strong era the most strong in my
thank you come on the strongest voice of
my own story so it'll play this strong
voice is a metaphor of where I'm at in
my Womanhood okay so I feel like watch
Transformers honestly I'm not just
trying to make this an ad but I really I
really appreciate the power that RC is
and I'm trying to tap more into that in
my life and stand firm and stand ground
you know what I mean so I think you know
watch this yes but also we know someone
else Family Affair coming out in Netflix
uh for me I would say
um
start with Justin give me what you got
five five yep start with five five yep
that was the first it's it's what the
Denver Nuggets come out to every single
game of their postseason and they made
it to the finals so if you start there
you can make it to the finals in
whatever aspect they're like oh God
come on
uh individual question for each of you
um yes you got to play at Coachella and
not only did you play at Coachella you
had Optimus Prime introduce you so I
need to know uh what the hell is it like
to have Optimus Prime introduce you
absolutely Immaculate something that I
never thought would be a possibility
ever in my life and as I saw it for the
first time I was just like
that's incredible that's that's
literally what I said that's incredible
this is something that I don't care
how big I get or how small I get ever in
life oh that's not a crazy part but
it's something that can like nobody can
ever say that they that they've done
that at Coachella yeah yeah it's the
biggest stage that ever performed on the
biggest
Transformer come on come on and biggest
franchise all in in at one time yeah
there's so many Powers Yeah
once yeah what followed that intro was
incredible too your performance was
immaculate
professional I have an individual
question for you uh I know how hard it
is to prepare for a red carpet I've done
these before and yes
and you uh did the Met Gala for Vogue
and not only did you you had to do the
outfit you had to prep for all the
people that were gonna come how much
pressure did you put on yourself to like
because you knew you were gonna get
crazy people yeah you know and you need
to deliver yeah well I'm the craziest
person so they were gonna have to meet
me and all this crazy so it really was
something that I I really prepped for
and that's not something I talk about a
whole lot you know you do the work you
keep the nose down and then you pop up
for the moment but I would say that
first year got a big old binder big old
Bible had my Anne Hathaway off to the
side telling me you know from Devil
Wears Prada My Girl My Assistant tell me
off to the side you know that's who knew
and what and what she's wearing that and
this and that was so helpful so shout
out to you
um but I second year I felt so much more
my power I knew what I was getting into
I had met people before I felt more warm
and comfortable on the carpet but it
really is about making that person feel
welcome to the party and making sure you
know they feel beautiful they took the
time to get ready today to see them see
the details see all that they've poured
you know the shaved face the everything
you know you know so much that a woman
and man and all people do to get ready
to feel their best and so you want to
make that person feel their best too by
welcoming them to the show yeah for a
minute I got lost in the sauce I thought
you were saying that you shaved your
face I was like I do shave my face okay
it's a nice exfoliage oh come on Jessica
Alba there's something inside Jessica
I heard you did it so I did it too
being specific about the film this movie
has tons of action uh humor it's one of
the best Transformers in the franchise
what are you guys most excited for
audiences to see in Rise of the beasts
all of the things that you've never seen
in a Transformers movie
that's what I'm excited there's a lot of
things that are happening in this movie
that is the first time that this type of
thing is happening in the Transformers
uh franchise so it's like yo experience
all the newness all at the same time
it's history yes literally and this is a
lot of mounting up to this moment too
that we've been waiting for yes
audiences fan members as members of
Reddit everybody and their mothers who
have been waiting to see Optimus primal
people have been waiting to see RC have
more of a backstory people have been
waiting to see all these details that
Stephen Campbell Jr so brilliantly
captured in his vision so I think it's
just gonna be a testament to the fan
that created it and to the people that
have been waiting for it individual
questions again uh I believe this was
your first time acting 100 was on the
set of this so what was it yeah yeah
random fact
he did this you recorded this in 2021 in
Moe's 2022. this guy this guy you're
special yeah you are a special name I do
I do my homework before I sit down so I
want to know what it was like for you
because not only are you acting for the
first time you're acting in like a 200
million dollar movie which is crazy you
know and I also individual question for
you what surprised you about because
you've done voice over before but what
what surprised you about voicing a
character in the Transformers Universe
and what it was like in the booth and
because you know you got to deliver a
performance but it's also this huge
movie so these are my last questions
gotcha gotcha uh for me it was
incredible because everything was
incredible but the way it happened was
uh absolutely uh uh amazing Stephen
reached out to Paramount uh through a
relationship that that he had with his
friend who put him on to the music uh so
we had no prior relationship I didn't
know who he was or anything like that uh
and I thought it was a prank when I
first uh got them I'm not even like
somebody had hacked my email and said
hey look pair my pictures want you to be
I was like ah yeah that's trash but it
when I when I found out it was real it
was a it just turned out to be a raising
from the absolute beginning conversation
all the way through the entire process
uh and and the experience onset with the
cast and crew that was like
Hollywood but not Hollywood if you can
understand what I'm saying they made it
extremely comfortable and seamless to uh
to just
flourish on the set so so that's me I
want to take a picture no and but you
were so brilliantly talented that they
wrote you into even more yeah come on
yeah they did they created more scenes
they saw the magic on set and wanted
more of it
listen you shut your truth I won't I
refuse but he's so brilliant I haven't
even seen the movie yet so I don't even
know what I'm saying
but I'm gonna safely assume you know but
uh anyways what was my question
they're doing voiceover work
um I mean this was something I genuinely
she's she's a Ducati 916. she is a
fearsome motorcycle yeah
she's Fierce so I I decided to ride
started cycling a stationary bike I
started writing a stationary bike I
really do cycle now and I love doing it
but honestly I started working out for
this role so I can feel as powerful as
her in the booth I wore like athleisure
I wore like tight like like leggings
just a few more of a stance so we're
like spandex to be more like a superhero
genuinely like it helped me reach a a
power versus wearing like something that
was a little more accidental you know
loose so I put on my costume I put on my
super suit and I popped into the
character and that was really fun to do
it was very different for me yeah that
no need to stop her they're gonna you
know grab the hook and just yeah I'm
just gonna say congrats and um wish you
guys nothing but the best